that intersection of uh innovation and
creating new knowledge
and actually applying it is what excites
me the most so
the what i liked about academia was like
the very deep
knowledge and getting into a subject and
being a
subject matter expert but
at the same time i saw a lot of
research for research sake which isn't a
bad thing just
wasn't for me welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
creating medical devices using
technology is pretty different than
developing other types of startups meet
in ba landsberg
chief business officer of medex
accelerator lp
inval has an intensive scientific
background with a phd in bioinformatics
from tel aviv university
and post-doc in bioinformatics from
stanford university
she is the founder of two companies one
in biospecimen procurement
and the other in personalized supplement
recommendation in balance berg welcome
how are you
great thanks for having me thank you for
joining me it is my honor
a phd in bio bioformatics you're going
to tell me a little bit about what that
means in a second from tel aviv
university postdoc from stanford
today working with medex accelerator
and all about digital tech in healthcare
devices
and medical you know an industry
is probably the most important one to be
diving into today we've
seen over the past year the incredible
advancements i can only imagine how
exciting it is
to be running an accelerator for this
industry in
in these times and i'm excited to hear a
little bit about you and about your
journey and how you got to where you are
so
take me all the way back you know what
what really got you into this space
wow well i always liked biology ever
since i was a
third grader i think um
so that was always in the background uh
most fascinating
um subject and i started off
um trying to heal cancer as any other
biology student will tell you the reason
that they signed up
and then i found out i didn't like the
labs
um at all and i thought well
computational could be a good solution
so
what what is the labs that when you're
saying the labs what do you mean the
biology lab uh actual being like a
labyrinth like wearing a white coat and
mixing
the white coat yeah mixing up
heating up it's a lot like cooking if
you like cooking then typically you like
that i
was not that great at it and i did not
like that
and i did like biology and i don't like
just
like repeating something i like doing
something and then moving on
to the next thing and learning a lot and
then kind of moving
and all the time and in a lab you have a
lot of repetition
so i decided that wasn't for me and then
at the same time i discovered the
computational biology which was kind of
booming up it was the age of the human
genome
so that was sounded exciting and i
decided to
enter bioinformatics so you you decided
to enter that world
both with a phd from tell me university
tell me a little bit about your work
with
stanford obviously place that's also
very close to to my heart you also
worked quite a bit with sloan school of
business
so what was that environment like for
you
yeah so stanford was really a place i
wanted to get to i visited one summer
and then i decided that's where i'm
studying
and i'm so happy and grateful it ended
up that way
because it's a really vibrant and
exciting place to be
um i kind of had
the opportunity to do something very
similar to what i did in my phd
so that was kind of like a more natural
continuation of same subject
protein structure and a binding site and
finding binding sites
i worked at russ altman's lab there
at and and so you're
sitting there the intersection with
business and product and you know the
the
you know i'm saying on one hand you're
saying i don't want to be you know in a
lab with white coats i want to do you
know more
computational stuff but at the end you
know your day-to-day
today is centered all around this
integration of
the research with society right i mean
that's
i i'm assuming that's what takes what
that's what happens in this incubation
that you're running
first of all i'm not running i'm just
the business officer we have a ceo his
name is shai poliker he's running
the incubator just to be accurate about
that um
so i think yeah that intersection of uh
innovation and creating new knowledge
and actually applying it
is what excites me the most so the what
i liked about academia was like the
very deep knowledge and getting into a
subject and being
a subject matter
expert but at the same time i saw a lot
of
research for research sake which isn't a
bad thing just
wasn't for me and i was
much more excited about actually finding
something that
can make a difference in the world and
in the world and
be translated into actual products
and um at stanford they have
all kinds of entrepreneurship programs
and i was uh
lucky enough to be in the summership
program summer and program for
entrepreneurship
and i got the bag and ever since i
i founded startups i worked on on
in on innovation getting startups uh
as part of it and in the incubator so
it's been
around that area right tell me a little
bit about
research you know for the sake of
research versus
you know application of what it could
be for society because it sounds like
you know coming from your perspective
both you know
deep into academia so very technical
very research oriented at the same time
understanding that you know there is
that there is a gap between
you know the the research aspect and the
implementation for society
what what what sort of have you learned
about
this struggle or this dissonance over
over your years in the space
so i think um many of us um
and i'm talking from academia for a
second
we don't learn how to think business at
all
people can graduate and don't know how
to read the contract
or don't know how to think about markets
don't have
basic vocabulary of what a market need
is never seen a procedure
done in an operational room or even at
in video so there's them
so many gaps that kind of
[Music]
stream people into staying with the same
line of thinking which is
academic only and i think that that's a
big
gap that exists and i think part of what
we
all need to be doing is provide more of
this tool as part of
basic education and definitely academic
education
so do you see as primarily an education
issue that it needs to be taught in
academia
in a you know in a school setting is
that is that
in your mind you know what would help a
lot of people that are already in
academia
get exposed to this yeah i think this is
part of it
um a big part of it and you can see
um the difference between people that
were exposed to
industry early on and people that were
not
and in the way of thinking there's a lot
of
kind of uh ivory tower type of thinking
that this
is a superior and such and if you go to
industry
you hear a lot of the same but just the
other way around
so it's just i don't think any of them
are correct it's just that we need to
provide
the tools for both and early on as
possible
so do you see yourself as sort of the
connector
in the middle between these two worlds
right now
um i i wouldn't say i'm the connector
i'm just a chain
and there are many uh of us um
the tech transfer offices and uh on one
side and
uh the incubators and accelerators on
another side and then once we are also
just part of the
chain and then later on you have the the
corporates and they have their own
divisions of
early stage innovation because what's
mature for us is still early for others
and so it's just a long long chain so
tell me a little bit more about
medics accelerator you know what is it
about
you know what is sort of the vision and
and how does it actually play into the
ecosystem around us
okay so we are uh an incubator
despite the name we are an incubator for
medical devices
and uh we work with one of the
biggest players which is uh boston
scientific
and other investors medics
medics ventures and sheba medical center
and so with all of these partners
we actually invest in early
stage companies and projects sometimes
it's just a need a clinical need with
nothing else
and we bring on um
the team and create the ip and kind of
build the
company ground up and sometimes we get
lucky and we find
kind of more mature startups that are
ready to go and just looking for seed
investment
and we invest in them um
a little short of 1 million
and we kind of incubate them for two
years
and bring them to whatever their next
milestone
is which can be funded for round day and
we had quite a few success stories
what is the incubation process any
different
for companies that are coming in you
know in the medical devices space that
are coming to you versus you know some
that may come to other accelerators or
other incubation programs is there
you know a difference in mentality or
process that that is unique to
medical devices yeah
um i don't know if the process is unique
because it's for medical devices
but i can say and um that's different
and i can say because i
was fortunate enough to to work in a
tech transfer office and also see other
incubators and i
how they work before coming to medex
accelerator
is that here the involvement
is is is really hands-on
we have a weekly meetings with the
ceos every aspect of it
we write presentations together as a
team
it's not like there's an entrepreneur
and there's management
and they have to present it it doesn't
work that way it's just a team of people
working
uh together um also entrepreneurs
working with
one another it's a very um kind of
cooperative type of
uh working environment and i think that
makes a lot of
difference yeah tell me a few of the of
the fun success stories from
uh from medics accelerator i'd love to
hear about them
okay um so we are quite a young
incubator
been around for about four years now so
the
we have one cohort that graduated and
in that we had caps medical
that did a very successful
round a uh of about four million
i think that there was um
they they do uh called plasma
uh for solid tumors that's one of the
the major
successes uh out of the incubator and we
had endowed
that disposable robotics um
that was actually purchased uh by
ascendum
uh just uh just this year
um others exero medical which is just uh
fundraising now and and uh addresses an
asthmatic leaks so these are leaks uh
in the gi uh gastrointestinal
system after typically colorectal cancer
and so they have this devastating state
of
people looking great after the surgery
but then developing over a few days a
leak which
could be life-threatening and so they
have
a device an implantable device that's
biodegradable and you can detect it very
early on where you can still
save life and do something about it and
so
you know how does your day-to-day look
like
in in a place like this you know whether
it's during a cohort
preparing for a court i'm sure it's two
uh
two different mindsets and but what is
your
what is sort of your day-to-day like
within a medical devices incubator
so there are a few different pillars uh
the business development i'm in charge
of the deal flow so this is uh
projects coming in so we do
meetings and interviews with
entrepreneurs
trying to evaluate projects we see
about 20 30 a month
and we choose about three or four
a year so that's a lot of filtering to
do
so we move the projects kind of down the
funnel
from lead to qualified lead to do full
blown due diligence
and with growing um involvement
at what stage are they coming to you
in in their life cycle
yeah it really varies um some come
when they already have a developed
product
but that you couldn't sell and they need
to um
shift and we help them find a new
indication that's one way about it
um others come with a paragraph
this is the need that i've found and
and actually we like both wow
that's that's very very cool and so you
know if you're looking at
you know medical devices and for
somebody who's you know
outside of the space and doesn't really
know much about you know
medical devices or or you know really
what's what it's like to to go into that
space you're not thinking of myself as a
young entrepreneur
i realized that you know these sorts of
companies are some of the most
you know life-changing ones and
and i'm thinking well what what can
outsiders do to
put themselves into this space you know
somebody who doesn't you know study
computational biology or a biologist
what can they do to come in and make an
impact in the in this space specifically
i think we all have some degree
of exposure to help
on our daily lives uh we all have
relatives and and
issues ourselves so whenever you found
something that doesn't have a good
answer and good medical answer that's
always a good place to start
so finding um
the the problem the issue something that
doesn't work for you if it's
uh inconveniency going to a diagnosis
or just some hurtful procedure
or find the need so the most important
thing is
the need right finding the need and i'm
sure that part of the
challenge is also understanding and
identifying what the need could be
especially when you're when you're not a
domain expert in a space like this and
if we're looking you know a few years
down the line are there any interesting
observations that you're thinking about
or you're seeing
interesting movements especially you
know over this last year
anything that we can you know look
forward to either optimistically or
pessimistically
well for seeing the future is always
difficult
but definitely we see a lot of digital
health getting into i don't think
that that's news to to anyone but you
see it more and more
um taking taking up space and and
getting into
many of the devices i think
about half of them have some type of
algorithm
uh to some type of data component and
um as part of the device itself so
that's
we see that more um
as just well we have one project that's
kind of in the spirit of coved with just
physiotherapy
a very promising company called
synchrony medica
which i think we will see more of so
a lot of uh post-covered
issues are just physiotherapy
and venus problems so i think we might
see more of those uh
solutions wonderful involved thank you
very very much for joining me i have a
few
fun questions left are you ready
okay we'll start off easing we'll get a
little complicated down the way
and first off your favorite subject in
school
that's easy biology i think we started
with that
when when did you start with biology
what was the first time you got exposed
to biology
third grade i was in a special program
for excellent students and there was a
specific lesson that i remember that the
teacher showed us
how the um how the blood works
and antigens and i said this one i want
to learn that
i love it okay one of your role models
or
somebody that you look up to that really
inspires you
well i don't think i have a one specific
person i try not to
idolize anyone in specifically but i do
try to uh take characteristics from
people
so i try to imitate like do my actions
like
someone so i uh try to give
presentations like uh shy and i try to
do small talks
like david and uh i try to host like a
karen so
that type of behavior very cool and the
last question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
difficult
i would say achiever
and a mom and uh
outdoors i love it
thank you very very much and best of
luck with everything
and thank you for helping you know
companies
early stage medium stage whatever stage
it is making a positive impact and
continuing to grow
i really appreciate you taking the time
and until then
you know stay safe and stay healthy
[Music]